after landing in London tomorrow morning  Donald Trump will switch Air Force One  for marine one traveling in the  helicopter it's a wind filled house in  Regent's Park after that the President  and the First Lady will receive their  royal welcome from the Queen the Prince  of Wales and the Duchess of Cornwall at  Buckingham Palace while royal gun salute  are fired at the Tower of London and  Green Park the Queen will then host a  private lunch inside the palace next the  first couple will travel to Westminster  Abbey where they'll lay a wreath on the  grave of the Unknown Soldier then Prince  Charles and Camilla will have afternoon  tea with the precedence at Clarence  House in the evening mr. mrs. Trump will  travel back to Buckingham Palace in  marine one where they'll attend a full  States banquets both the Queen and the  US president will make speeches before  the meal